alors si tu pense qu'il faut un réflexe
une caméra red un truc nous vendre un
vin pour faire des vidéos cool ben
écoute regarde cette vidéo jusqu'à la
fin et franchement tu vas changer d'avis
[Musique]
hop
salut à tous j'ai tard que vous avez
bien moi je suis en vacances donc c'est
plutôt cool le cadre est pas est pas
vilain du tout c'est vraiment sympa et
justement j'en profite pour faire cette
vidéo parce que je suis partie super
légers j'ai laissé tous les boîtiers
canon 5d 6d à la maison et j'ai décidé
de partir avec mon smartphone avec un
stabilisateur le dj os mobile 2 et avec
mon spark et accessoirement une petite
go pro parce que je savais que j'allais
faire des plans soumah pourquoi ce choix
tout simplement parce que je savais que
j'avais marché beaucoup que j'allais
avoir plein de choses à trimballer et
que je sais pas si vous avez déjà porté
1,5 des sur un stabilisateur gens
craignent 2 c'est super lourd c'est
super encombrants et je voulais pas
m'emmerder veulent aussi profiter du
paysage voulait profiter de mon voyage
mes vacances mais aussi voilà faire des
vidéos de qualité donc il ya quelques
petites techniques quelques petites
subtilités pour arriver à faire des
vidéos avec un rendu cinématiques et on
va en parler tout au long de cette vidéo
et puis vous montrer qu' il ya vraiment
pas besoin d'avoir du matos dessous
c'est avec ce que vous avez dans votre
poche et quelques petits accessoires on
peut arriver à avoir vraiment un super
emploi
ouais
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
donc première chose on va parler de la
stabilisation ce qui est super important
si vous voulez des mouvements de caméra
un petit peu cinématiques et forcément
les mouvements de caméra ça va jouer sur
la qualité de la vidéo
donc moi j'ai hésité pendant pas mal de
temps entre le zii une smooth coût 4 et
le 10 james bond mobile deux qui sont
dans des prix relativement similaires
c'est dans l'ordre de 150 euros à peu
près et finalement j'ai opté pour le dj
l'os mobile
tout simplement parce que j'avais
beaucoup aimé la première version que
j'ai testé vous pouvez les voir
d'ailleurs la vidéo s'affiche sur votre
écran vous pouvez cliquer dessus pour
aller voir le test les fonctionnalités
sont relativement les mêmes il ya
vraiment pas de nouveauté si ce n'est le
prix le stabilisateur je pense que c'est
vraiment l'allier qui va vous permettre
de donner un tyran du le petit plus
finalement qui va faire que votre vidéo
va être vraiment sympa ah oui au fait tu
es petite précision je voulais pas dit
mais je suis sur l'île de la réunion
d'où le cadre un petit peu paradisiaque
vraiment vraiment sympa c'est cool ça
fait plaisir de soleil ça change
[Musique]
o o
oh
[Musique]
au plat de résistance on va parler du
smartphone alors là en l'occurrence
j'utilise un iphone disent oui je sais
j'avais dit iphone dit c'est pas pour
moi etc
mais je les achetais d'occase il m'a
coûté vraiment pas cher entre guillemets
c'est beaucoup moins cher que si c'était
neuf et il a un super bon capteur donc
on va pas faire un débat sur quel
smartphone est le meilleur vraiment là
c'est pas ce n'est pas l'idée les
smartphones
il ya un hélicoptère qui passe au dessus
mais ça devrait le faire les smartphones
actuels sont quand même vachement un
vachement performants les capteurs sont
vachement de performant il ya moyen de
faire des choses même si on verra à la
fin il ya des limites à ce qu'on peut
faire et surtout au delà du smartphone
il ya des petites astuces qu'on peut
utiliser je vous avais déjà parlé dans
une autre vidéo de l'application
filmique et là je me suis vraiment
régalé pour plusieurs raisons déjà il
c'est très simple de régler l'exposition
vous avez un petit cercle blanc que vous
pouvez déplacer sur la zone que vous
l'exposez la laïcité fait en fonction du
ciel donc vraiment pas mal on peut gérer
le focus également pour avoir un petit
peu d'effets bloquée même si le capteur
est pas énorme énorme
on a quand même cet effet flou d'arrière
plan qui est sympa donc se rendre du
cinématiques on va la voir comme on a vu
grâce à la stabilisation on va l'avoir
grâce à filmique qui va aussi nous
permettre de filmer en mode flatte ou en
mode log alors personnellement je vous
recommande plutôt le mode flotte
peut-être que c'est moi qui ai pas su
m'en servir correctement mais le mode
blog était vraiment très désaturer
j'avais beaucoup de mal à récupérer la
couleur alors que sur le mode flat
c'était beaucoup plus simple le mode
flotte vous allez avoir une image très
délavé
mais vous allez pouvoir retravailler
derrière votre couleur votre
colorimétrie beaucoup plus facilement et
pour avoir un résultat qui est beaucoup
plus sympa au final autre point positif
de filmique on va pouvoir gérer le
nombre d'image par seconde la résolution
on peut aller jusqu'à de la 4k à 60
images par seconde mais là on n'aura
plus le mode log le mode flat on devra
avoir la couleur naturelle du capteur
pour qu'on a le stabilisateur on a le
smartphone et surtout on a filmique qui
marche sur ios et android aussi qu est
payante mais vraiment on l'a rentabilise
elle est excellente cette application
vraiment vraiment excellente allez c'est
reparti ah oui et puis il ya un petit
truc sympa c'est ce petit trépied là
pour poser qui m'évite d'avoir un
trépied en plus de l'eau ce mot j'avais
amené mongori la mode mais finalement
j'en ai pas eu besoin du tout et
ça c'est un petit truc trois pieds là
qui se vissent sous le haut ce mot
petite nouveauté parce que c'était pas
présent sur la première version du cosmo
et franchement c'est ultra pratique et
dernière chose que je voulais vous dire
à propos de l'iphone et du lot ce mot il
ya pas mal de gens qui ont eu des
conflits de stabilisation parce que il
faut savoir que l'iphone est stabilisé
physiquement légèrement et que la
stabilisation en plus du gumball duo ce
mot peut rentrer en conflit alors pour
le moment je n'ai pas eu de soucis ou
vraiment des choses très légère mais
surtout j'ai pas couru avec j'ai juste
marcher j'ai fait des plans relativement
lent j'ai fait du solomo donc je n'ai
pas ressenti ces petits ces petites
ondulations qu'on peut avoir ses petits
conflits qu'on peut avoir entre le
l'iphone stabilisateur physique de
l'iphone et le dit mme balasko
[Musique]
et dernière petite chose pour forcément
avoir des plans un petit peu plus variés
c'est le drone et la gopro alors en
brawn j'ai pris mon petit ce parc qui
est bas le plus petit pour le moment de
ce que fait dj hype qui a une petite
autonomie
un capteur pas ouf non plus et des
fonctionnalités qui sont pas présentes
sur le mavi pro ou macbook air par
exemple le truc c'est que si vous voulez
investir pour pas cher des comme ça on
en trouve dans les 350 euros en occasion
donc ça permet d'avoir des plantes de
drones vraiment sympa pour pas cher
attention il prend un petit peu le vent
quand même un l'aï seyfried et des
petites des petites branle et là par le
vent juste sur les plans que je viens de
tourner donc faut faire gaffe
et encore une fois ça permet de varier
les plans se dire que ça va être autre
chose que de la caméra tenue à la main
on va vraiment pouvoir prendre des
paysages on va vraiment de pouvoir
donner une autre dimension à la vidéo et
de suite un petit côté un peu plus
cinématiques un peu plus pro même si
c'est un petit capteur même si c'est pas
le meilleur drones du monde
surtout il est tout petit il rentre dans
le sac encore une fois on parlait dans
le comblement au début de la vidéo
là dessus c'est vraiment top et à leurs
petites astuces j'ai investi dans ce si
ça coûte 15 euros sur amazon ce sont des
filtres mde le titre nba en fait c'est
les lunettes de soleil pour capteurs
parce que effectivement là je suis dans
un endroit qui est très ensoleillé même
si on est le matin même si on est venu
tôt on a vite des blancs cramer on a
vite vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
lumière donc ça va permettre d'atténuer
un petit peu de lumière d'avoir une
vitesse d'obturation un peu plus longues
et donc des images plus nettes
alors c'est pas la grande qualité c'est
15 euros sur amazon mais franchement là
aussi ça suffit amplement et j'ai
vraiment pu avoir des images bien
contrasté bien-être avec un beau piqué
surtout qu'ils ont obtenu voilà de la
taille de la bestiole et des capacités
du capteur et enfin pour finir la gopro
alors c'est une vieille groupe pro et
ont quatre un truc que vous trouvez à
100 balles sur le bon coin donc vraiment
ça coûte rien elle a une autonomie de
merde faut le dire elle n'a pas dû 120
fps en 4k etc
mais franchement on s'en fout tout ce
que je voulais faire avec c'était des
plans sous marins je voulais filmer les
petits poissons et là pour le coup
clairement ça valait le coup parce que
je ne pouvais pas le faire avec mes
autres appareils et c'est quelque chose
qui coûte que dalle donc voilà je pense
qu'on a fait le tour des équipements que
j'ai amené pour ce voyage pour faire
cette vidéo j'ai à peu près fini mais
roche j'en suis à peu près content j'ai
commencé le montage est ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va tout de suite
regardé des extraits de cette vidéo et
moi je vous retrouve juste après pour la
conclusion pour savoir si oui ou non
l'iphone 10 plus l'os mobile plus les
petites les petits accessoires qui vont
avec abbas a suffi pour faire un film
avec un look cinématiques
[Musique]
alors conclusion de ce test du dj os
mobile 2 avec l'iphone 10 est-ce que ça
remplace un réflexe pour faire des
vidéos alors clairement non si on prend
des appareils comme le gh5 comme le
saunier à 7,3 ou les canaux 6 des 5 d on
est clairement très en dessous en termes
de qualité vidéo par contre pour
répondre à la question est ce qu'on peut
obtenir un rendu cinématique est
vraiment de très très belles vidéos là
c'est clairement un gros gros oui même
en terme d'investissement si on calcule
un petit peu tout ce que j'ai amené
comme matériel que ce soit l'iphone plus
le dj rios mobile plus le drone plus la
gopro on est en dessous du prix d'un gh5
par exemple avec quelques éléments
acheté d'occasion et surtout on va
pouvoir varier les plans puisque le gh1
qui veulent pas et il va pas sous l'eau
et d'ailleurs c'est qu'est synesthète
qui disait il vaut mieux avoir cinq ou
six plants à peu près potable plutôt
qu'avoir un plan parfait parce qu'avec
un plan parfait on rencontrait alors
qu'avec cinq ou six plants à peu près
potable dont on peut raconter une
histoire et au delà de ça ce qui m'a
beaucoup plu dans cette expérience c'est
la facilité d'utilisation
c'est léger ça sort facilement on peut
shooter tout ce qu'on veut et à peu près
quand on veut donc ça c'est vraiment
vraiment un gros gros plus fluide avec
les embruns avec la pluie avec le sable
j'avais un petit peu moins peur quand
même de sortir mon appareil alors par
contre la grosse limite que j'ai vu le
truc qui m'a vraiment gonflé c'est la
plage dynamique de l'iphone là pour le
coup
quand j'expose et à certains endroits
j'avais des noirs qui étaient
complètement bouché ou alors des blancs
complètement cramé avec ce type de
matériel il faut vraiment des conditions
de lumière optimale et une composition
vraiment travailler donc ça m'a quand
même un petit peu plus coûté en terme de
temps pour faire les bons plans pour
bien cadrer bien composer mes images
mais bon c'est le revers de la médaille
et on peut pas tout avoir en même temps
la facilité d'utilisation et quelque
chose de forcément fou en termes de
qualité d'image
j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé ce compromis
et je pense que les prochaines faut je
partirai pas je partirai léger comme ça
ça suffit amplement
voilà les amis c'est tout pour
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est bientôt
l'heure de rentrer malheureusement dans
la grisaille française j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
mettre beaucoup de câlins blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui situe juste en
dessous de la vidéo
abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas déjà fait
et moi je vous dis à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]